we'll cover the very latest from the
Washington swamp in a moment but joining
us now with more on the president's
executive action is American
Conservative Union Chair match slap
Florida congressman Matt Gaetz
and Fox News correspondent larger my
buddy Geraldo Rivera in studio good to
see you theory let's start with this
declassification order congressman I'll
go to you first you've given that you're
up there on the hill is this the moment
the Spygate a co-conspirators here have
been dreading forever this
declassification order sure is Monday
night as a matter of fact on this show I
predicted we were days from action and
weeks from evidence I think what's most
important about this executive order as
it shows that Comey clapper and Brennan
all are in jeopardy if this was just a
question of misconduct at the FBI the
president wouldn't have given the
Attorney General sweeping authority to
be able to compel the production of
evidence from the intelligence community
from the CIA from the NSA and that's
where I believe there is evidence that
was withheld from the FISA courts where
George papadopolis is saying we weren't
colluding with Russians that would be
illegal that was withheld now you
mentioned the gang of eight briefings
Dan and what's so important about that
is that they included statements of
exculpatory evidence evidence that would
have shown that Carter Paige and George
papadopolis were not a basis to continue
this investigation and that is not going
to line up with what was presented to
the FISA courts and so that disparate
display of the evidence I think is going
to really show where the corruption
occurred and they should be very worried
or although I'll go to you next it's
good to see you in studio mayor listen
they're in a world of trouble right now
I mean congressman gates brings up a
great point when Attorney General Bill
Barr is up on the hill in his testimony
he didn't just say the FBI he was very
clear there was possible malfeasance
with the Intelligence Committee and he
was very specific at large they're not
just the FBI so this may be bigger than
just FBI spying and I think their days
are numbered and hiding this story a
couple of points I think bed first of
all to watch the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and the President of the
United States going at each other like
junior high students is very
disheartening I think that this is
really not good for the country this
sniping this personal sniping in the
speaker's case however what is revealed
by her you
of the terms cover-up and so forth
leading up to her meeting on
infrastructure with the president is
that the agenda of the speaker has been
exactly in sync with the most radical
members of the Democratic caucus she is
thinking impeachment she wants to prove
obstruction of justice with all her
might but what is happening is when
these documents are revealed what it
will show is an obstruction of injustice
the president's frustration is his
flailing out at the Democrats is because
he committed no collusion there's no
underlying crime it's not Watergate and
people are using that peril using that
analogy including our own Judge
Napolitano are way off base because
there was no collusion
there was no obstruction in his
obstruction of injustice but I think
that this is dangerous this this
reckless rhetoric both from the
president and the Speaker of the House I
think they better cool it right now
maybe the Memorial Day weekend I'll give
them some time to to ponder it but as
this evidence comes out I want to know
at what point did the special prosecutor
know to a reasonable certainty that
there was no collusion why didn't he
tell the president then when he got to
that point that there was no collusion
was he trying to entrap the president in
a perjury rap I really think that the
cello I don't blame the president at all
for being upset you're accusing the
president of a cover-up in a crime I
don't have any more upset but so mad
going to you cookie what kind of sass
cue what's the ledge you've been around
the legislative arena for a lot longer
than I have is the legislative purpose
of all of this the Congress is not the
FBI Matt their oversight and their
investigative abilities it correct me if
I'm wrong here our to legislate not the
but I'm the junior FBI well you know
they do have an oversight responsibility
which is baked into the power of the
purse and their ability to fund the
government so they do have legitimate
oversight what they do not have a
legitimate right to do is to have their
own prosecutorial investigation which is
why it's the proper thing for bill Barr
who by the way the Attorney General has
been undergoing an investigation for
quite some time now so
fact that the White House is now taking
this extraordinary step which we've been
waiting for for months and months and
months it probably means that this is
well enough along where they have a
grasp of what they want to declassify
what needs to be made public and Dan
here's the key two key things number one
this is going to take the wind out of
the sails of impeachment because it's no
longer about all the faux coverage of
potential wrongdoing for Donald Trump
which has been proven to be completely
wrong
it's now gonna be about the obama-biden
administration what did they know when
did they know it what did they do what
didn't they stop why did they use their
powers in an unauthorized and
illegitimate way to go after their
political opponents this really puts the
shoe on the other foot as Geraldo is
saying it's not about president Trump's
wrongdoing it's about what happened
during those Obama years and I think
this is nothing but positive for the
American people who want to get to the
truth yeah congressman you're up there
you're living with this every day is
there your rise ability here that that
when Bill Barr talks about this being
bigger than the FBI if you live if you
watch the Lisa Paige testimony in
Congress she seems very confused that
some of the information the FBI was
getting may have been given to the CIA
as well a matter of fact she doubts that
could have happened even though it seems
appear apparent based on Brennan's
briefings up on the hill that the
sources were the same is it possible
there were parallel paths yet it all
went back to Christopher Steele in the
end the strongest evidence that those
parallel paths existed is that you have
Brennan and clapper and Comey all
starting to point fingers at one another
about the extent to which the dossier
funded by Democrats cooked up by liars
and then commingled with Russian
information wasn't really the driving
force of this entire investigation
and so I think that as we get closer to
the target you're going to see more of
the circular firing squad start among
those people who are so desperate to
derail the Trump presidency that they
took illegal action before a secret
court that had no defense attorney and
you know to Geraldo's point about the
level of the discourse here it is really
strange to hear the Speaker of the House
question the president's mental state
what I see is that this question about
impeach
is torturing the Democratic Party and so
if the president needs an intervention I
think that Nancy Pelosi and the rest of
her caucus all need to go on dr. Phil
and talk about their feelings
the prisoner goes there the president
should be above that you know he doesn't
need that he's winning now let let let
bar do his job you've got him you can't
walk he's not just done they'll be
they'll be uncovered and we'll see who
did what well Bart did we just look at
today the things that I was able to get
16 billion to our farmers he was able to
negotiate through a gridlock on a
disaster response
and he was able to centralize this
investigation on the greatest political
scandal in American history that's a
pretty good day for somebody who needs
an intervention I gotta run guys but
it's funny that when when Mullard punts
the football to bar and he does his job
then the democrats complain about to
Matt congressman gay want to do over
again like Wayne's World member that do
coke ulis thanks a lot guys appreciate
it